[Music]
eat the pie I equals negative one is one
of the most famous equations in math but
it's also one of the most confusing
those watching this video likely fall
into one of three categories one you
know what each term means but the
statement as a whole seems nonsensical
to you were lucky enough to see what
this means in some long formulas
explaining why it works in a calculus
class but it still feels like black
magic or three it's not entirely clear
what the terms themselves are those in
this last category might be in the best
position to understand the explanation
I'm about to give since it doesn't
require any calculus or advanced math
but will instead require an
open-mindedness to reframing how we
think about numbers once we do this it
will become clear what the equation
means why it's true and most importantly
why it makes intuitive sense first let's
get one thing straight what we write is
e to the X is not repeated
multiplication that would only make
sense when X is a number that we can
count 1 2 3 and so on and even then
you'd have to define the number e first
to understand what this function
actually does we first need to learn how
to think about numbers as actions we are
first taught to think about numbers as
counting things and addition and
multiplication are thought of with
respect to counting
however this mode of thinking becomes
tricky when we talk about fractional
amounts very tricky when we talk about
irrational amounts and downright
nonsensical when we introduce things
like the square root of negative 1
instead we should think of each numbers
simultaneously being 3 things a point on
an infinitely extending line an action
which slides that line along itself in
which case we call it an adder and an
action which stretches the line in which
case we call it a multiplier when you
think about a number as an adder you
could imagine adding it with all numbers
as points on the line all at once
but instead forget that you already know
anything about addition so that we can
reframe how you think about it think of
adders purely as sliding the line with
the following rule you slide until the
point corresponding to 0 ends up where
the point corresponding what the adder
itself started when you successively
apply two adders the effect will be the
same as just applying some other adder
this is how we define their sum likewise
forget that you already know anything
about multiplication and think of a
multiplier purely as a way to stretch
the line now the rule is to fix 0 in
place and bring the point corresponding
with 1/2 where the point corresponding
what the multiplier itself started off
keeping everything evenly spaced as you
do so just as with adders we can now
redefine multiplication as the
successive application of two different
actions the life's ambition of e to the
X is to transform adders into
multipliers and to do so as naturally as
possible for instance if you take two
adders successively apply them then pump
the resulting sum through the function
it's the same as first putting each
adder through the function separately
then successively applying the two
multipliers you get more succinctly e to
the X plus y equals e to the x times e
to the Y if e to the X was thought of as
repeated multiplication this property
would be a consequence but really it
goes the other way around you should
think of this property is defining e to
the X and the fact that the special case
of counting numbers has anything to do
with repeated multiplication is a
consequence of the property
multiple functions satisfy this property
but when you try to define one
explicitly one stands out as being the
most natural and we express it with this
infinite sum by the way the number E is
just defined to be the value of this
function at 1 the number isn't nearly as
special as the function as a whole and
the convention to write this function as
e to the X is a vestige of its
relationship with repeated
multiplication the other less natural
function satisfying this property are
the Exponential's with different faces
now the expression e to the PI I at
least seems to have some meaning
but you shouldn't think about this
infinite sum when trying to make sense
of it you only need to think about
turning adders and multipliers you see
we can also play this game of sliding
and stretching in the 2d plane and this
is what complex numbers are each number
is simultaneously a point on the plane
an adder which slides the plane so that
the point four zero lands on the point
four the number and a multiplier which
fixes zero in place and brings the point
four one to the point four the number
while keeping everything evenly spaced
this can now include rotating along with
some stretching and shrinking all of the
actions of the real numbers still apply
sliding side-to-side and stretching but
now we have a whole host of new actions
for instance take this point here we
call it I as an adder it slides the
plane up and as a multiplier it turns it
a quarter of the way around since
multiplying it by itself gives negative
one which is to say applying this action
twice is the same as the action of
negative one as a multiplier it is the
square root of negative one all adding
is some combination of sliding sideways
and sliding up or down an all
multiplication is some combination of
stretching and rotating
since we already know that e to the X
turns slide side to side into stretches
the most natural thing you might expect
is for it to turn this new dimension of
adders slides up and down directly into
the new dimension of multipliers
rotations in terms of points on the
plane this would mean e to the X takes
points on this vertical line which
correspond to adders that slide the
plane up and down and puts them on the
circle with radius one which corresponds
with the multipliers that rotate the
plane the most natural way you could
imagine doing this is to wrap the line
around the circle without stretching or
squishing it which would mean it takes a
length of 2pi to go completely around
the circle since by definition this is
the ratio of the circumference of a
circle to its radius this means going up
pi would translate to going exactly
halfway around the circle
when in doubt if there's a natural way
to do things this is exactly what e to
the X will do in this case is no
exception if you want to see a full
justification for why e to the X behaves
this way see this additional video here
so there you have it this function e to
the X takes the ad or PI I to the
multiplier negative 1
[Music]